[Music]
good morning afternoon and evening
everyone welcome to the stanford mba
alumni panel for people who are
interested in the broader technology
arena
my name is carrie oliver and i'm your
host today and we'll start in a few
minutes
because it'll take a little while for
people to be
let in from the waiting room so i want
to just welcome you
and thank you for being here that's also
to our alumni panelists
and please feel free to open up the q a
pod
and uh introduce yourself your name and
where you're calling in from today
because it's always fun to see
who's with us and uh we could just we
get to wave back
my uh my name is carrie oliver again and
and i am an mba admissions officer and
also an alumna of the mba program
and my background ranges from public
policy to early stage
um internet and sas companies and also
have been in ag tech so
you'll see some of those industries
represented on our panel today
we're going to be spending the next 45
minutes together
and based on some feedback we've had
from candidates
our guests in the past we're going to
extend that five or ten minutes
if you need to leave at the 45 minute
that's fine
but if you want to stay a little bit
longer you're welcome to do so also and
that goes for both the panelists and for
you because we did originally
say this would be a 45 minute session
i'm going to
have the panelists introduce themselves
and then what i'm going to do is
moderate questions from from you
while we are here today and i think it's
really exciting to have a panel focused
solely on the tech arena
broadly speaking i just wanted a quick
you know flash up some quick statistics
you know we have a very broad
um base of students that come from all
kinds of different backgrounds and
industries
and even within these the types of jobs
that people
have within their organizations you know
vary by function
and and focus area but
no matter what career you choose either
before or after you come to stanford
we really encourage our students to
to seek out opportunities that play to
their personal values and interests
because when you're doing something you
really love you tend to do it better and
have a bigger impact
so let's get down with the panel uh so
again
people from four four uh five uh
panelists
uh ranging in their various clash years
including two who just graduated
um again pointing out that if you have
questions of the panel please use the q
a box uh to ask that panel and do the
upvote
but uh panelists i'm going to ask each
one of you to offer very brief
uh background about yourself for an
introduction your name in class you're
up here but maybe maybe the city you
grew up in and your current city
and maybe every bit of context around
your career path and what you're doing
today
and then ask i want you to answer one
question
and then we'll move on to audience q a
and that is
uh well stanford we like to really help
people expand their mindsets and think
broadly so i'd love to know what your
favorite academic experience was
while you're here on campus and tamar
why don't we start with you we'll go
left to right
hi everyone thanks for joining my name
is tamer nisbett
i'm originally from brooklyn new york
and stayed in new york for college where
i went to columbia
and i majored in comparative literature
so i'm a little bit different than a lot
of people who are at business school and
maybe did something that's
a little bit more traditional that you
would think of um
after college i first worked at a high
school in diversity and inclusion and
then made my way to california to work
at google in account strategy
and finally ended up where i really
loved which was youtube
and so i worked in media and
entertainment before um and my team
was the content team and we wrote
youtube's entire health center
um and i knew that i wanted to probably
stay in media and entertainment but i
wanted to be
on the strategy or finance side so i
considered doing consulting
but got my dream job on the content
strategy team at netflix which is a team
that does evaluation and strategic
forecasting for what shows should be on
the platform
and i just started on monday so after
this i'll be going to my third day of
work which i'm really excited about
um my favorite academic experience
was a class called formation of new
ventures with
jim ellis scott brady and garth saloner
they
are amazing two of them are just
wonderful entrepreneurs and then
greciliner is a great professor who
studies entrepreneurship
um and we read cases about someone who
had started their own
venture every single class and then that
person would come into class
and so we would get to discuss what we
thought they should have done which is a
little bit scary when they're right in
front of you
um and then they would say exactly what
they did and why um and we'd have a q a
and it was just
a class that was full of energy um and
light and i think it will actually
really work well on zoom too
so it gives me hope for this year's
class that's gonna take it
in front of virus
hi everyone thank you all for joining
and good morning
my name is fabian schwartzman i was born
in argentina but grew up in israel
i did my undergrad and masters in
chemistry
that's my background then i went to work
at intel as a process engineer and as a
group leader
and then i was lucky enough to be
accepted to stanford and ever since i've
been working at a company called
aerofarms
we're the leader of the vertical farming
space
[Music]
which isn't some egg tech plus
other stuff today and i lead our
business development and innovation
efforts
and i think the the most interesting
class for me
uh or the best experience academic
experience that i had
um was probably the
there's a class called the industrialist
dilemma uh
that was taught in my ear by uh rob
siegel and aaron levy the ceo of box
and that was a really really cool class
because we had like
people like the ceo of ford coming in
and the ceo of
uh you know was like very old and
becoming a caterpillar
talking to us about how caterpillar is
using autonomous vehicles for example
our autonomous tractors
for their um for their work and it's
been
really really cool to see you know not
only the
the silicon valley uh innovation but
also how
the incumbents respond to that
awesome hi everyone i'm nan uh
great to get to virtually meet all of
you um i'm from chapel hill north
carolina i currently live in
san francisco um i
i went to harvard undergrad and and
after that
did a kind of brief stint in consulting
um
i sort of quickly learned about myself
that i care a lot about the problem
space that i'm in
um and since then have basically been in
and out of climate tech
and so i worked at oh power nest um
uber specifically working on uber pool
more people fewer cars
and and i'm actually at stripe now
uh working on uh building a new climate
team so
can talk more about that later but
climate has sort of been the problem
space theme
that i've been passionate about for a
long time i've moved in and out of
different um functional roles in product
and business
and have sort of gone back and forth
between gme pme stuff for a while
um my favorite academic experience i
loved so i took a class
called managing growing enterprises with
joel peterson and the whole
kind of crux of the class is focusing on
challenging interpersonal
um situations and the it's like two
hours of just
tough situations um that are very eq
focused
and i would i would say i use the tools
that i learned in that class
almost weekly if not more um
and it was very it was a very
enlightening and sort of um
it was a wonderful class and i think has
helped me
sort of get into a more of a growth
mindset for a lot of the eqe stuff that
we all inevitably face over our careers
and lives
awesome i'll go next so my name is jason
scott
i'm currently based in new york i
actually moved here in march
um so it's been an interesting a few
months um
i started my undergrad at mit i was
actually pre-med
and majored in biological sciences um so
things have changed
but i went after college into consulting
um in the life sciences and then
made the pivot into entrepreneurship and
startups um
pretty sporadically right before the gsb
working at homejoy
um and then after the gsb kind of stayed
in
the startup ecosystem uh short stint and
venture capital at highland capital
partners
um and then a few hopped around to a few
other subs and now i'm at google running
our startup developer ecosystem for the
us
which is kind of a the nice venn diagram
of many of my interests and prior
experiences so it's been a great uh kind
of journey
um to get here in terms of
classes and i'm horrible with favorites
but so i'm probably gonna pick two
um i will say that um one that i use
pretty much every day
um which is interesting and unexpected
to me um is this class that's
called path to power and it's all about
actually understanding power dynamics
and
and generally leveraging that to
accomplish an
impact and i think for me um the
interesting part about that
is just how do you understand power
dynamics in
in the workplace and just generally in
life and and just use that to accomplish
goals and those goals can be um to have
um to accomplish a lot of social good
which is
um personally which personally resonated
with me um but then i will be remiss if
i didn't mention interpersonal
dynamics which i'm surprised no one
mentioned as well um
and um a fun anecdote um my tea group
actually we still meet
i'm the group of 12 that you um that you
go through interpersonal dynamics with
we actually still meet and met
on sunday for three hours um still four
years out so
it's been kind of ongoing um an ongoing
impact in my life so that's been great
as well
thank you um hi guys my name is cleo so
excited to have you here today thank you
for giving us part of your day
um i grew up in a small town in rural
vermont
and i was lucky enough to get sort of
just full financial aid
to harvard where i studied english
literature and
then didn't totally know what i was
going to do and happened to find my way
to
amazon out in seattle where i currently
am i had a wild ride at amazon
there for five years before business
school the first team i landed on was
actually the video games team
uh which i knew nothing about but got to
sort of live a teen boy's dream life for
a couple of years they're like
comic-con was a business trip um and had
a lot of fun sort of learning about the
e-commerce
business and then i eventually
transitioned into uh the digital
advertising business which at the time
was quite new at amazon
and the fun thing was at that point i
was focused on health and wellness
um so a lot of kind of fun consumer
brand you know
launch strategy go to market stuff like
that i
been you know i was lucky enough to to
come to the gsb um interned at google
last summer and i'm excited to be
joining next week uh
doing global business development my
favorite academic experience the gsb oh
i'm with jason it's very hard to narrow
down favorites um
i i have to say i think one of the
opportunities that i enjoyed the most
was actually this option called the 390
independent research project so
um in case folks aren't aware of this
it's i think personally it's like a
hidden gem of the gsb
so basically what it is is if there's a
ton of great classes that you can
you know sort of meet a wide variety of
interests but if there's something you
want to learn about that
isn't already a developed course you
basically can make your own and so what
that
means is um like i would team up with a
classmate so i could have the experience
like you know working with a buddy and
almost kind of testing like a co-founder
dynamic uh and then a faculty member
you sort of propose it a faculty member
sponsors it and then you really are kind
of off to the races to learn about
whatever sparks your curiosity so
during my time at the gsb i did a 390
research project on cyber security
did one on developer productivity and
kind of devops and i did one on
psychedelic medicine so
really it's a choose your own adventure
but i appreciated the gsb was so
supportive of intellectual curiosity
you guys make me want to go back to
school
um thank you we actually have some very
popular questions
online and um it's gonna be hard to
select so i was gonna actually try to
steer this towards one or two of you but
i'm just gonna
i'm just gonna let this one go and if
two or three of you want to wave your
hand or string your microphone on so
will
and 13 14 other people are really
wondering
whether or not and how the d school
impacted
or supplemented your learning at the gsb
and
it's also asking if you know about
extracurricular resources available gsb
students i
presume around i'm not sure the context
around that one but the uh
um but you know did you go to the d
school and how did it add and were there
other things that really helped you
bolster your intended career um in the
short from long term
who wants to go great fabian
okay so yeah so i i took one no actually
i took
two or three classes at the d school uh
so like some of them are really really
good like i remember specifically a
class called
i think from play to innovation
uh which is kind of like a
server consulting class like we have
three cases
uh during the quarter way where we have
to help companies
um with their with
some of their tasks so and so each so we
get divided into groups of three or four
and then we have to do something that
will have some element of play
uh and we'll have to present some some
options to
to to the company so for example in my
in my year we had the stanford
uh blood donation center i mean
they try to help us we try to help them
uh increase the the people who
who donate blood and we also had
not patagonia the other company
[Music]
not columbia the third company not not
columbia not patagonia
uh coming and like it was really cool
like the ceo came to the class and we
all presented him and
it's it seems like you know
since it's involves play it could
look a bit silly but it's actually like
there was a lot of thought going
there were some really cool uh projects
material
let's say you say go for it jason yeah
no i was gonna say i
also um i took a class called d
health and i think in general the design
school what's awesome about it for me
is just really being able to to dive
into a space
that you're really really interested in
and passionate and really for me
check the box or uncheck the box of if i
really want to
pursue this after the gsb and i think
i'm going into the gsbi
most of my career had been in life
sciences and health and wellness
and i think for me um this class allowed
me to really explore
the entrepreneurial side of that and and
working you work directly with patients
and really understanding your customers
and consumers and
and the folks that you're trying to help
and i think um for me it actually
allowed me to make some decisions and i
think answering the second part of this
question
um around um extracurriculars um
at the gsp i think in general for my
my recommendation um and take it with a
grain of salt is
um to try as many things that allow you
to either check or
cross things off of your list that that
you want to really get hands-on
experience
in the industry or in an entrepreneurial
setting or um something that you're
actually trying to
um potentially pursue as a path after
the gsb and i think for me
um that was the approach i kind of
applied throughout most of my classes in
extracurricular activities as well
anybody else want to talk about the
d-school
okay so they another very
very popular question here is from
andrew
and i think i'm going to direct this uh
initially at
ja nan and jason um
because it's you all had a degree of
tech experience
prior to arriving at stanford do you
think it would be hard for a student
to pivot to tech without any private
prior experience
um i i can speak i can well you guys are
the admissions panel is probably um also
uh well-positioned to
to speak to this a little bit but
i have seen people in my class and i've
also hired a number of people that
that have not had traditional tech
experience
um i think what is really amazing about
stanford in particular if you want to be
in tech and you want to be in the bay
area stanford is an incredible
network of people for you to get to know
both in your class but also
inter-class um i have seen a number of
my
own classmates do this and i again have
hired a number of people who didn't have
a traditional tech background
i think that um stanford like it is not
a guarantee but i think it
very stanford in many ways greases the
wheels to make that
to make that um transition a lot more
seamless
yeah and i would say the only thing to
add is i generally advise people to take
the almost think of it as like a step
function and in general
like maybe you don't have the functional
expertise but you have the industry or
vertical expertise or maybe vice versa
but
um there's always something that you can
add and it's just about
finding out what can you add to those
teams because similarly i've hired
people who've
had a variety of experiences but there's
always something that they add that's
missing from my team
that's really impactful
would anybody else like to answer that
question
i can just say that i got into check
without any background in it
so um and and two two out of the reason
i called on on
jason and anna is that they had other
careers before they got in so i don't
think you need to get a gsb
mba to get into tech but it certainly is
a great way to launch
um anonymous has a popular question
and again it's like i want to invite all
of you guys if you have an interest in
answering this one
why did you decide to go to business
school and why stanford
specifically and there's a sub question
which is how has that helped you
in your career
teamer yeah go for it and then we'll go
with cleo
um i i love answering this question so
when i was at youtube i i was on the
content strategy team
and i often worked with a product team
and i really wanted to transfer the
product
so i applied to an open role there like
a role that i knew incredibly
well and i got an i got an interview and
i
made it to the final round and at the
end i didn't get
so um you know proactive me went to my
director and i asked like why
didn't i get the job and she said you
know
we really love you we love working with
you but i just don't know if you
can learn the tools required to do this
job uh
like you majored in literature like
you've never used excel before i just
don't know if you can do it
and i just remember feeling so hurt in
that room because i was like
i can definitely learn how to use this
tool this is a tool that
like millions of people use i think i
can learn it um
and i just never be in a position where
someone could assume that i wasn't going
to be able to learn something
and when i looked at even this woman and
all the other people who
like were at a high level on the
business side of youtube they all had
mbas and so it really inspired me to
like buckle down and take the gmat and
apply to get my mba
um and then stanford specifically
because it was in tech it was in
california
i considered going back to new york
where i'm from um because i'm interested
in
tech and media broadly but on the media
side
so much more so many more interesting
things i think are happening in los
angeles where i currently am and in san
francisco than in new york which is more
innovating on older companies so i
really wanted to be in california
um and then how did it help post mba i
think stanford has been a huge help to
me so far so
i mentioned that i was on a team that
did a lot of writing and i also worked
on influencer monetization and like a
little bit of partnerships before
and the team i'm currently on is the
finance team at netflix so i'm literally
like actually in excel doing something
that someone told me that you didn't
think i could do
um on a daily basis valuing content and
that's not a job that i think i could
have transitioned to actually without an
mba at all
so going from a content team to a
finance team is something
that was really important to me and that
was really helped by the mba
um and then going to netflix
specifically i think was really helpful
to go to stanford where there are lots
of connections to netflix already
thank you taylor um so i i also love
this question it's one of my favorites
that we that we get in these types of
settings so um
so i've been in the tech industry for
about five years when i was sort of
kind of at this tipping point of okay
i've always wanted to back my mind that
i wanted to get an mba i've sort of
had this dream but um you know maybe
some folks on the call might be
struggling with
it's hard to know it's hard to know sort
of when to like
take that pause and be like okay i'm
gonna step away from the workforce for
two years
you know i really do empathize with
folks who are thinking oh well you know
the salary this promotion you know
it's it can be a very challenging
decision um however
the thing that sort of finally made it
very um
the thing that made it easy for me i
should say to say yes to the mba was
when i take a step back and think about
sort of the overall arc of my career
most of us are probably working for
about 40 years give or take right like
if you start working roughly around age
22 and you
you know more or less work to let's say
like age 62 four decades is a very long
time and
when i sort of take this like macro
level of view i thought well if i take
two years
especially in that first like decade or
so of my career two years
you know sort of step off that you know
treadmill that is you know full-time
work fast-paced whatever
and if i deeply invest in myself and
learn as much as i can
and meet as many good people as possible
and travel as much as i can and sort of
really really kind of like deeply invest
in
broadening my horizons sort of exposing
myself different opportunities
who knows what the balance of that
trajectory will look like right and so
as i sort of took that macro level view
it's suddenly like oh if i take two
years in that first quarter let's call
it
who knows what the trajectory with the
shape of the rest of that time looks
like
but that feels like an investment very
much worth making and as far as why
stanford
honestly gsp was my dream i didn't i you
know i'm being super candid here i
didn't think i was going to get it i
didn't get to stand for undergrad and i
remember thinking like what if stanford
doesn't like me
um but it's there was just so much about
the program that was really important to
me so
the fact that there's such a big
emphasis on eq right you know the other
panelists have mentioned
uh classes like touchy-feely or
interpersonal dynamics um we also have a
culture
or a tradition i should say um called
talk which is basically once a week
classmates share their personal stories
and kind of like a long form almost like
30 minute
very um very sort of like deeply
personal
storytelling you know even small things
like ama's asking anything like you'll
do that on you know bus rides all you're
going to and from various places and i
think
there's something very powerful about
the authenticity and vulnerability
of the gsb community and it's sort of
like i imagine many business schools
could kind of give you the hard skills
and teach you a different flavor of
leadership but
at least for me personally if i was
going to be any kind of leader i wanted
to be a leader in the gsb
way which is sort of that balance of
warmth and competence um
and i think in a way that's just very uh
very human um and so
as far as fit goes i mean that was kind
of like the sort of spiritual alignment
tactically i mean just as tamer said get
it i mean if
if you're on this call you're interested
in tech there's no better place in the
world than silicon valley i mean the the
sheer
richness of opportunities and i say this
is someone who's like worked in seattle
a big tech company
it's a whole other ball game uh here in
the valley and it's it's
a privilege to be right at stanford
where everything is in your backyard i
mean
i literally went on a tech trek to like
apple park lunch which is usually like
pretty hard to get to
um and visiting startups and you know
vcs
there's just so much there's so many
opportunities during the two years that
you're a student
to really explore the field in a very
hands-on way that you might might be
challenging elsewhere
um and to the last part of the question
on like how did it help post mba
each thing that i'm involved in right
now is thanks to stanford right so
you know i'm about to start a job at
google i had 16
different gsb alums help me on my path
as in
interview prep informational networking
preparing for the internship interviews
navigating google once i got there
helping me negotiate my return over
16 different alums helped me on the
google front alone the other sort of two
buckets of things that i'm involved in
right now
one of them is actually entrepreneurship
so um over the last couple months the
stanford professor and i have been
working on a startup idea which is
something we're
sort of continue to be doing as a fun
and interesting side hustle in the
in the months to come and then the last
chunk is actually around angel investing
so i know nothing about angel investing
or i
didn't until recently but because of
some of the work i'd done at stanford
um i was able to to get involved and
make my first angel investment recently
so across sort of like the google piece
the entrepreneurship piece
and now angel investing like doors are
opening to me that never would have
opened if it wasn't for stanford
jason did you want to answer that
question i saw at one point you had your
microphone off
you don't have to answer it not much to
add i would just
echo that the the proximity is um
incredibly powerful and i think
um whether it be just an investor or a
startup just coming to campus for lunch
um
[Music]
you just have so much access to the tech
community there that i think um
is is invaluable in many ways so i'm not
not my staff involved
great so another popular question here
is really around leadership
leadership skills and
i'd love to have maybe we'll start with
nan and
fabian because we haven't heard from you
just the last couple but also invite
anybody else to answer this question
that how is
how does stanford influence your
leadership skills
it's in the workplace but i would just
invite you to to see if it goes beyond
the workplace also
oh okay i can go first um
so i think for me one of the
more influential classes when it comes
to
leadership was actually touchy feely um
because or what we call our
interpersonal dynamics because
it's a class it's like when you hear
uh alums and people who took the class
talk about it sounds really weird
it's basically 12 people sitting in a
sitting in a room without any subject
without any topic to discuss
um but eventually like
you get a ton of learnings of that and
specifically how
your actions impact others um
and while some of that is also
like you is all you you also get to
experience in
in leadership in lead labs i think that
for me at least the touchy-feely aspect
and taking the full class and learning
more about how
what i say impact other people really
really helped me hone my leadership
skills
obviously classes uh like were mentioned
before like
mg managing growing enterprises uh
leadership perspective
all those really really help as well
just you know hearing
how other people are dealing with
uh tough situations uh
you know even eventually even like
things like view from the top when you
hear like really really
top executives coming and speaking
pretty frankly about uh some of their
current challenges or previous
challenges
uh i think that that all really really
helped me
uh hone my my leadership skills
yeah i think um i think if you think
you're going to graduate from the gsb is
like a fully
formed ready to go leader that's
definitely a misnomer
um i think for me personally
what i found really valuable is sort of
two things one was seeing a lot of
different
examples of what leadership looks like
and there are so many different examples
and there are so many different
leadership styles and there is not
one right leadership style for even a
given person i mean the
the way that you lead i think it does
shift in context
it shifts over your career it shifts
it's sort of a function of a lot of
different things
um i i personally thought that exposure
to all of those different styles was uh
it sort of opened at my aperture for
what it can look like
and then it sort of leaves you this
question of you know what are the
what feels authentic to you and i think
that part of
that part of the journey is something
that you you obviously
probably have already started but like
you start and and make progress in that
part of the journey
at the gsb but uh
it sort of takes your whole i mean it
takes your whole career to figure out
exactly what kind of leader you
want to be what kind of leader you are
and sort of build and
and um kind of evolve your style and
those skills
um but i think that you know if
the gsb places a big emphasis
on authenticity and trying to figure out
kind of what what feels authentic to you
and um it ultimately gives you
a good sort of ex again exposure to
different
examples of what leadership can look
like and you can take those and
and and work with those for the rest of
your career
amen or jason or cleo anything you
wanted to add
i would i would also add that i think
stanford does a really good job
of empowering women to look at what
different types of leadership
looks like um one class that i can think
of
is there's a class from fern mandelbaum
who's
a wonderful professor who works at um
emerson collective and it's about women
in entrepreneurship
and there's another class from laura
aryaga andreessen which
is called like women in power or
something similar to that which i was a
course assistant for um and i and in
in normal classes i think professors
actually try to do a really good job at
showing diverse leadership
and making sure that we have
international ceos who are coming making
sure that we have ceos of color making
sure that we have ceos from the lgbtq
community
i think that's really powerful and i
also really appreciated the classes that
were
really specific to women um and have
been having people like sheryl sandberg
come to class and like have that be
normal
um or priscilla chan and being able to
ask them questions about what their
leadership looks like
and to really just see myself
represented and some of the people who
came to class
which i wasn't sure what actually
happened when i came to stanford
and i was really pleasantly surprised
and really proud of the institution for
all the efforts that they put there
because
it's been intentional and i think that
that's really important to know as well
yeah and one thing i would add that i
hadn't heard already is that
also at stanford you just get an
opportunity to lead on campus right or
just
your classmates and i think um if you
think about it all of these are
future leaders of organizations startups
corporates
enterprises and by practicing leading
amongst your peers
i think you you get you gain a lot of
useful skills that you might not realize
then
even if it's just planning um a
get-together or
a dinner or those things you learn how
to manage managers and learn how to lead
leaders and i think that's really
um been something that i've carried with
me as well
thank you guys there's a couple of
questions there's four
centered around career management and
some things we've already touched on
like if somebody doesn't have a tech
background what might they want to think
about when they're at the school
but have any of you use the career
management center and know people who
did
and if not then what other choices do
you have for
informal um job searches or more
directed
job searches
and i don't know how you guys found your
job so you're going to have to raise
your hand thanks
tamer um i may stop at this and go first
so
depending on what type of tech role that
you would like to have
uh you're more or less likely to get
that job through the
career management center and so what i
mean by that is like for
big tech um and like just larger
startup companies in general you can
find those at the career management
center so
any of like the fang companies are going
to recruit on campus
um some of like the bigger media tech
companies will also come recruit on
campus
and also there's i think there's like
one or two days where
uh startups actually come to campus and
you can go to the cmc
and there's like a fair type of a thing
and you can meet a bunch of different
startups
so that's only though the companies that
have a relationship with stanford so if
you're interested in doing
something um with a company that's like
totally new or with
people who went to who didn't go to
stanford so maybe there's not that
um relationship with the career
management center
then you do have to go out of your way a
little bit um
but the one is that the career
management center can help you
can help put you in contact with alumni
so if you do find an alarm at a company
that you want to work with
really easy to reach out through the
career management center or through some
of the directories that we have at
stanford
the other thing is the stanford.edu
email
is quite powerful like um although i got
my job through the career management
center i
similarly to cleo did a 390 and i was
reaching out to people like very cold
either on linkedin
or because i had their email somehow and
i i probably got like an eighty percent
hit rate with responses
and so just know that if you
if you do wanna do something that's a
little bit um out of the ordinary
like your chances of actually talking to
someone who's doing what you're doing
are quite high uh and the last thing
that i'll say about that
is one way that i know a lot of people
got their jobs was actually by doing a
project in class about that job and
reaching out to a person and saying hey
like i've been working on this problem
look at this research i've done
and you've done it for class anyway and
then you can show the person that you're
reaching out to
what you've done with your stanford.edu
email and so
kind of thinking of the best ways to
cold email people has really worked
i think for a lot of people i know and
they were able to get the startup jobs
that they really wanted
cleo and then papian
yeah completely really want to
underscore teamer's point so
i think there's this tendency in
business school sometimes think of
things in buckets like well this is my
career time this might get in my time
this is my social time
you can you can multitask like i as much
as possible tried to do what tamer said
which is
use your academic experiences as a way
to professionally network so there's a
popular class at school
called managing growing sales teams and
your main project for the class is you
pick a company and you learn about their
sales team
my background's in sales i was like i
want to pick a company where i might
want to work one day and use this as a
chance to sort of
network within that business do a
research paper circle back with a map
and provide that research
um i happened to choose the company
airtable they're up in san francisco and
so my whole project team and i got to
like drive up to the city for a day
and spend a day with three or four
different folks at hair table which is
a pretty you know powerful opportunity i
think there's also just a different the
context feels different when you're
reaching out i think
for an academic purpose versus a job
right like formal recruiting is very
structured and sort of like the walls
are up and it's very
you know evaluative i think there's
something very powerful when it's more
curiosity driven so
again on the point on 390s like you know
i think it probably talks like eight or
nine cyber security companies maybe a
dozen or so devops ones
15 or 20 on the psychedelic side and i
have i sort of i'm of the mind that if
you do enough
outbound you will eventually get some
inbound right so if you talk to enough
interesting companies that are in the
fields you're curious about
you eventually will get sort of pieces
back and the last thing that i'll say
just sort of add one other
you know hopefully maybe different
flavor to this is whatever research
you're doing
if you're able to actually take that
content and publish it like on medium or
gsb has a student publication called
nondisclosure anything you can kind of
do to sort of share with the world what
you're doing
raises your kind of visibility in that
field so to jason's point around the
class path
to power very powerful um sort of like
almost like road map to how can you
become known in a space right because
it's one thing to be applying for
existing jobs and we're
you know we all got to do that but in
the ideal state jobs are coming to you
right and so the way that that happens
is i think by having a sort of
network in the spaces you're curious
about but also having established
yourself to whatever you
extend that you can as a thought leader
in the fields that are interesting to
you
that's just what i would add on there
yeah i just just wanted to add that in
addition to the
academic experience that includes
classes like now i think in my cl my
year was the first time that we had a
project
a product management class so i mean so
so there are some
academic work that can be done but in
addition to that like you know like
you'll have
classmates that has been all over the
place they've been
in this in all probably in all possible
industries all possible roles so you'll
definitely if you want to
if you want to switch to a specific
quality a specific company you might
have someone that you can talk to and
learn more and then maybe that person
can also connect to the right people
at that company um so i just want to
acknowledge just quickly um the
time is uh if you originally scheduled
to
finish this call at uh at the 45
um please feel free to stay on for the
next couple of minutes
i'm going to stay on and hopefully one
or more of our panelists could stay on
for an extra
five to ten minutes after that we'll
land closer to um great
well closer to um uh well our morning 8
55
so if you are going to sign up um thank
you so much for being here and i hope
you heard some things that
helped you know a little bit more about
our program
um and we have a lot of other events
that are taking place over the summer
and you can take a look at our events
page on the website and see which ones
interest you including small group chats
with a student or an alum or an
admissions officer
or i saw that there was a popular
question here about admissions overall
and i would actually bring those
questions to one of our information
sessions with an admissions officer
who's going to be better equipped to
answer those
questions um so i actually want to
just nana i don't want to cold call you
but i think what's really intrigued me
about your background is that your
your passion is around climate and you
happen to find that home in tech
was there any particular reason that you
chose that avenue and how did you get
there
um so i was i mean i'm trying to
remember exactly how i was thinking
about this like
after consulting many years ago but
basically
i was trying to i always tried to lay
out after consulting what i thought i
wanted to solve for
and one of those things was a
space that you know i i call it my 2 a.m
test well i'd be excited to work on this
until 2 a.m
and for me that that climate falls into
that bucket the second thing was
um i wanted to work at a fast-growing
company with other really smart people
and there are definitely tons of
opportunities to do that outside of tech
but tech is one of the places to find
that
um and there happened to be at the time
like two vc backed clean tech companies
which were basically opower and nest
um i applied to opower and was fortunate
enough to
to get a job there um
so it was sort of the intersection of
yeah it was the intersection of the
problem space but also wanting that fast
fast growth environment and um
and great people climate is a weird one
and i don't want to rattle on this
because this probably won't be
interesting to everybody but i think
that
like climate there are opportunities for
for
for climate and tech to overlap there
are more
opportunities where they don't overlap
in my view and i am at stripe for a very
specific
thesis around making a market for carbon
removal in the absence of policy which i
definitely won't go into now
um but i think that um
i think there's like sort of a slim
overlap in that venn diagram and if you
can find it great but then you have
if you can't you have to make a decision
of which do i care about more
do i care more about tech or do i care
more about the problem space
i haven't had to make that trade off
quite yet but i imagine that i will in
the next 10 years thank you
there's a couple of questions that i
think are probably best directed to
fabian and jason but i'm not i'm not
sure
which is engineers can often view mbas
with skepticism in the workplace
have have you dealt with that or have
you had to deal with that deal with that
and how would you mitigate it
i'm happy to go first i guess um so yes
i will say there are a lot of people um
also on the engineering and tech side
who i think
question um or questioned me when i when
um i was deciding to
go to gsp but i think um ultimately it
goes down to just knowing why
you're going to business well i think
you should know this in your application
anyway and
and someone has already asked us like
why are you going to the dfc why are you
interested and were you looking to get
out of it
and if you feel confident in that and
you feel confident that you're actually
going to acquire a new skill explore a
new vertical explore new space
meet a great network etc if you have
actual
goals for that time then i think it um
leaves you a little bit more confident
that um that you're you're going up for
the right reason and that you're going
to get
the value that you need out of it so i
don't worry about it personally but i
i yes of course um there will always be
for any
decision you make people who ask you why
you made that decision
yeah for me i was exactly the same like
i
i had a technical sort of a technical
role before business school and so
for many of the people that work with me
or people that um
what i when i reported to her they
reported to me like there was
like i got this question like why like
you know like if
you're good in the technical side why do
you want to go and do business
and especially coming from a country
like israel where the mba
is not considered that great because
it's very easy to get one
um so but i i knew internally like
what i believe in why why i want to do
that and that's
that's basically what made me continue
that was the answer i gave everyone
anybody else like to answer that
okay you know um i i'm gonna actually
ask a question that's kind of hinted in
a lot of these things but we haven't
really
um quite touched on it which is
extracurricular activities
um whether they're related to your
current career or
not um what is what would be your
favorite or favorites
jason and cleo um extracurricular
activities
uh when you are a student or maybe even
as an alum
and i'm gonna open that one up to
whoever waves their hand or takes their
microphone off
go for it cleo we're happy to speak to
this one and conveniently i think this
hopefully addresses another question i
saw in the chat which is just around
sort of like the global experience
requirement which i know we haven't
really touched on
um i feel like i majored in organized
academic travel
at tsp so as folks were probably you
know possibly aware
um at some point in the two-year
experience you have to at least one
called the global experience requirement
so
this can be a week-long like global
study trip during the school year it can
be a
global seminar which happens basically
the week before you begin
your first year of school it can be a
month-long you know gmix which is based
like a
internship that's typically hosted in a
particular country
working at one business for four weeks
um and
you know so you have to do just one of
those i want to do three because there's
just so many interesting opportunities
um so for example uh one of my favorite
experiences of the whole two-year
experience was actually this
week before school started um i did a
seminar it's called a global seminar
about the ethics of tax avoidance and it
was
in switzerland in the netherlands i
remember thinking oh my gosh what's this
is school it turns out was you know
it was academic it's taught by two tax
professors who are um but essentially
looked at this question of like how can
governments use tax policy um as a way
to sort of
tip the tip the scales in their favor
economically um
i'm also curious about education i had
been in the joint degree program with
the ed school
when i started at stanford and there was
another educational
focused trip that was basically looking
at singapore and malaysia
and how education specifically was a
major factor in kind of the divergent
outcomes of those two countries so got
to go in country in both places and
learn about that
actually from their from their ministry
of education which is quite powerful um
and then last but not least you know
curious about entrepreneurship
and got to spend a week or so in cuba
learning about how entrepreneurship
looks against the backdrop of
you know sort of a communist country
which is really sort of interesting
transition point
um in the country's growth so all this
to say if you're looking for sort of
academically rigorous and just very um
i'd say like intellectually enriching
travel purposeful travel i would call it
there are myriad opportunities
um and that was a big area where i
focused a lot of my time and energy at
school
um tamer or jason did you you guys were
really involved with talk was that one
of your favorites or whether was there
an
affinity club or industry club that
really stood out to you
i will um i'm happy to go first um i
will say for me i probably
admittedly um did too many
extracurricular activities i think that
one thing i will flag is that there are
so many
opportunities at gsu whether you are
planning
um and participating in global
experiences or running
talk or running um we used to have a gsb
production
it's called the gsb show and there's
also student government and there's all
these
other clubs you can be head of venture
capital club etc so
i think um one thing that i probably if
i had to go back and do it differently
would be
maybe um prioritizing a little bit
better because i tend to want to do
everything um
but i will say at the end of the day it
goes back to what i mentioned earlier
that it was a great opportunity to
really learn
how to lead and manage your peers and
like organize your peers and i think
that
does directly translate to um as you
are working with these same types of
people in the workplace so
um i will say all all of it wasn't for
nothing but i definitely
probably did my balance and my scale was
probably a little bit too much in the
circular activity
side of things um
yeah i think i was probably similar to
jason and that i did quite a bit
and could have better prioritize but
also i think i learned
so much from that so in addition to some
of the stanford
extracurriculars like i was a top coach
so i went to every talk and helped some
people write their talks
um and an arbuckle leadership fellow so
as a second year i helped lead first
years through
a bunch of different like leadership
programs i also did some things off
campus so
cleo spoke to the the the
amazingness basically of living in
silicon valley um i actually
uh interned at a vc firm and at a
startup
separately at two different times my
second year and that was
amazing because i really wanted to see
what it was like to work at a startup
um because i went to stanford and i was
like okay maybe i want to do this and it
was
wild and crazy and i loved it and i
needed to come back to netflix which was
exciting but definitely working at
startups is something that i feel more
confident about
doing in the future because of that
experience um and i want to learn about
venture capital and so i became a
venture capital fellow at pair vc
which is a 10-minute bike ride from
campus and got to actually go
to the office all the time and meet
founders there and listen to pitches
and so it was really such a good
experience and i think what's really
nice about stanford is you are
right in the valley like you're you can
walk easily to a lot of the places um
that you might want to intern at
and so it's really nice to take
advantage of that but you might sleep a
little bit less than you want to
thank you guys um so we are now pushing
up against the um
end of our session so i wanted to
um just quickly
showcase the cornerstone of the night
management center
which dedicated to the things that
haven't happened yet and the people who
are about to dream them up
and you probably got a sense that all
five of our panelists
are dreamers and really bring their
values and their passions
to not just their education but their
work it's very intentional i heard that
word multiple times today
so hope that some of you also are
our dreamers and perhaps you're
interested in learning more about
uh about stanford and so we do have a
lot of other ways to connect with us
over the next couple of months and
so rather than read this if you want to
take a screenshot or just visit our
website there's lots of events
we are not on campus right now but we
are answering phones and email
also and just change lives change
organizations and change the world now
we've got we got
five alums here who are on that mission
and i
also just really want to thank you um i
know nan dropped off both jason
cleo fabian and tamer for being here
today and also just thank everybody in
the audience for taking the time
to to learn a little bit more about us
and i hope you all have a great rest of
the morning afternoon or evening